[Música]
Hola son muchos los acontecimientos que
tienen lugar en una semana en el mundo
por eso aquí en France 24 tenemos este
espacio en el que analizamos y
conversamos sobre algunos de los temas
más destacados en los últimos cinco días
bienvenidos esto es una semana en el
mundo para conversar sobre los temas que
vamos a tratar en este programa
saludamos a Silvia Colombo ellas
corresponsal para América Latina del
Diario follas de San Pablo también es
autora del libro guano da cólera Silvia
Bienvenida al programa y cómo termina su
semana
Muchas gracias por la invitación una
semana muy agitada marcada
principalmente ahí por las elecciones en
Brasil y sus reflejos por la región
también analizamos aquí en francés 24 en
diferentes espacios y aquí en el estudio
de France 24 me acompaña a Camila
Sarmiento ella es productora y
periodista de temas internacionales de W
radio Colombia Camila bienvenida Gracias
por acompañarnos Cómo terminamos toda su
semana Santiago gracias por la
invitación aquí a France 24 un placer
acompañarlos el día de hoy una semana
muy movida también por los premios Nobel
y todo lo que ha generado y los debates
que ha generado todos estos premios tema
que vamos a tratar en este episodio
Camila Claro que sí acompáñanos también
con sus opiniones y sus comentarios y
también preguntas por supuesto a través
de las redes sociales arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral una semana en el
mundo comenzamos entonces hablando de la
ofensiva del ejército ucraniano los
territorios recuperados y también la
anexión de cuatro regiones ucranianas
que ahora son parte
consideración rusa los avances Fueron
confirmados por Vladimir saldo él es el
líder instalado por Rusia en la región
de gerson fue testigo precisamente de
cómo las fuerzas armadas rusas tuvieron
que replegarse ante el avance de los
ucranianos pero El Avance también tiene
lugar en otras regiones en la región de
Luján en saprilla el presidente
ucraniano Volvo y mercedeski en una
alocución en televisión enumeró uno por
uno las poblaciones que han sido
recuperadas los últimos días mientras
tanto del otro lado de la frontera en
Moscú el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
le daba la bienvenida a la federación a
esas cuatro regiones anexadas una
incorporación que por supuesto es
rechazada por buena parte de la
comunidad internacional pasó entonces a
preguntarle a Silvia sobre sus
impresiones sobre esta este avance que
está teniendo las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas que le están haciendo bombos
y platillos en las redes sociales en los
medios de comunicación como un gran
triunfo un gran logro de los militares
ucranianos
Y sí bien si bien hay que tener mucho
cuidado no al decir que son las veces
ucranianos una vez que
son las veces que quizás no significan
mucho en el en el conteo final de lo que
está pasando No todavía el conflicto
todo depende mucho de Rusia No yo estaba
viendo más temprano una una declaración
de la primera primera ministra de
Finlandia San Martín en que le
preguntaban a ella cómo veía El Fin Del
conflicto en la región y ella dijo solo
hay una manera de terminar el conflicto
de la región que Putin salga de esta de
esta guerra de esta guerra no O sea que
si bien hay que hay algo que celebrar
con el avance de Ucrania por otro lado
parece que todo está muy muy lejos de
terminar no muy lejos de terminar la
guerra parece que se va a prolongar o se
está volviendo un poco más lenta y fuera
de eso se va a ralentizar más por la
llegada del Invierno dificulta todo tipo
operaciones Camila aquí en el estudio
impresiones generales también sobre este
discurso un poco propagandístico tanto
por parte de Rusia con las cuatro
regiones que incorpora y Ucrania
diciendo que Está avanzando y que está
logrando que los rusos se replieguen
claro este discurso tiene algo muy
importante y es que intenta tapar eso
que pasa afuera y eso que pasa realmente
en Ucrania y es la vida real Putin está
perdiendo dos cosas muy importantes y
uno es territorio que para la teoría que
él maneja que es la teoría realista es
lo más importante Entonces al perder
territorio y al perder lo segundo que
son hombres se empieza a caer esa cúpula
que él está montando el pierde
territorio porque Ucrania recupera parte
del territorio que él aneccionó
ilegalmente y pierde hombres no
solamente porque pierde hombres en
batalla pierde hombres porque pierde
hombres de los rusos que ya no quieren
estar ahí que buscan salir que no
quieren luchar esa guerra que se busca
Putin y pierde hombres en su cúpula
ministerial porque también hay muchos
que no están de acuerdo con las acciones
que está llevando a cabo Putin entonces
Realmente está perdiendo dos cosas con
una economía muy desgastada y que viene
a preguntarse realmente va a lograr lo
cometido y es conquistar Ucrania Camila
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda a
la inversa ya le doy la palabra Silvia
en la incorporación de estas regiones
muy criticada a nivel internacional esta
semana el presidente Putin firmó el
decreto que ya había sido aprobado por
la duma las incorporó pero son zonas
donde él tampoco tiene plena presencia y
soberanía precisamente porque los
ucranianos han estado avanzando es el
caso de gerson donde el territorio que
él pensaba incorporar ya no es la misma
extensión porque los ucranianos están
avanzando la comunidad internacional que
dice de esto o esto es simplemente un
mecanismo precisamente para ocultar esas
pérdidas de hombres y esas pérdidas
territoriales Sí eso es un mecanismo
pero en la comunidad internacional
rechaza plenamente esto no tiene él como
avalar que esas esas ciudades pueden ser
ahora parte de Rusia ahora bolo de mí
selensky tampoco se ha quedado en Los
laureles tampoco se ha quedado dormido y
lo que ha querido es demostrar mediante
hechos y mediante cosas que puedan
demostrarse realmente que sí él está
recuperando territorio y que la guerra
realmente no la está ganando Rusia que
es algo muy importante y algo también
que vale la pena recalcar es el diálogo
que tuvo ayer el discurso que tuvo ayer
Celeste en la organización de los
Estados Americanos en donde decía
necesitamos el apoyo de toda América
Latina entonces también extendí esa
invitación a que todas las américas y el
Caribe se unieran a resolver ese
conflicto y apoyar ese conflicto a favor
de Ucrania Silvia paso a preguntarle
para que comentemos no sé cómo lo vio
usted pensaría uno que puede haber en
los próximos días una especie de
discusión rifirrafe de nuevo por la
central nuclear de sapori está dentro de
esa región anexada por Rusia pero que la
organización de la de Naciones Unidas
que trata los temas nucleares la sigue
reconociendo como una planta que es de
jurisdicción ucraniana Esto va a generar
un nuevo capítulo hay de discrepancias
que podemos analizar ahí la verdad creo
que esas es el gran capítulo de
discrepancias En lo que toca a este
punto de la guerra este momento de la
guerra que estamos viviendo no no solo
por el enorme peligro que es tener esta
esta esta
planta en en disputa por el peligro que
puede causar cualquier disturbio a
cualquier ataque a ella y si bien los
rusos dicen que ya la tienen la ópera la
operan los ucranianos no O sea cualquier
desvalencia y cualquier Ataque a los que
están
comandando la usina puede causar un
incidente parecido al Chernobyl O sea
que un tema muy muy muy muy sensible Más
allá de lo que estemos discutiendo sobre
Quién está ganando o perdiendo la guerra
no yo entiendo también que hay algún
tipo de división entre los los asesores
de Putin No eso estuvo leyendo las
últimas horas con relación a sus últimas
a sus últimas decisiones políticas no y
eso me imagino que por ahí puede haber
más que una presión internacional una
división adentro del círculo de Putin
podría ser con que el retrocediera un
poco en la guerra más que por presión de
otros de otros factores No sí Y también
vivimos hoy también tuvimos hoy en la
entrega del premio de Premio Nobel de la
paz y se esperabamos quizás que se le
ganara no como críticas con relación a
eso eso también es algo que se podría
remarcar como algo lo vamos a conversar
más adelante Silvia lo tengo en la
agenda del programa para discutir sobre
ese tema que piensan ustedes sobre esta
declaración que ha hecho el presidente
de Estados Unidos Joe biden sobre que
estamos al borde de un Armagedón nuclear
vuelve a poner todas las alarmas sobre
esta posibilidad que Rusia ataque
Ucrania con armas pequeñas de pequeño
calado nucleares pero armas nucleares o
un accidente que pueda ocurrir en la
planta de saborizada hago la ronda la
inversa entonces continuó con Silvia
le parece que este este tema se ha
tratado a nivel mediático como con mucho
bombo que se está tratando de alarmar
mucho a la gente y no sé si parte de los
medios ahí La idea de hacer mucho bombo
si es el presidente de Estados Unidos
que uses esos términos no ser presidente
de Estados Unidos está hablando de
Armagedón no son los medios los que van
los que van a hacer sensacionalismo A
través de eso eso es bastante
sensacionalista no o sensacionalista en
el sentido real de la cosa no no
figurado no Entonces
por lo que uno sabe de lo que tiene de
potencial nuclear Rusia
quizás estemos de hecho delante de un
gran peligro no por este lado Camila sí
no no se puede descargar descartar el
peligro nuclear definitivamente si puede
existir Y sí se puede jugar esa arma
Putin ahora la diplomacia sigue
existiendo sigue igual estando Joe biden
y sigue estando Putin y sigue existiendo
ese intento de conversación aunque no se
haya dado estamos hablando de que ya
lleva mucho tiempo esta guerra y la
discusión sobre las armas nucleares
también ya digamos que está un poco
agotada no quiere decir que no se vaya a
dar si quizás pueda darse pero muy
seguramente esa arma no no la vayan a
sacar a menos de que realmente Putin vea
necesario o sienta necesario esa
adhesión de Ucrania en su totalidad pero
realmente por el momento sí creo que es
más es más un bombo que se está haciendo
No no lo veo muy cercano un Camilo usted
habla de la farmacia como una carta que
todavía se puede jugar pero justamente
el presidente celenski dijo que con esta
anexión de estas cuatro regiones pues
una mesa de diálogos queda completamente
descartada por el momento eso que nos
dice vamos a seguir cubriendo esta
guerra esto se nos va a prolongar en los
titulares y en lo que viene de resto de
año esto se va se va a prolongar y lo
más importante creo yo es que la
comunidad internacional si va a tener
que intervenir ya sea diplomáticamente o
ya sea mediante el consejo de las
Naciones Unidas o mediante alguna
organización internacional pero yo sí
creo que esa va a ser la forma en la que
se va a terminar la guerra más allá de
ir armas mucho más potentes
sí De pronto hablar sobre una
negociación de dos partes en la que se
sienta selensky y en la que se sienta
Putin es muy difícil y verlo sin un
intermediario fuerte es muy difícil se
cree más Sería más que podría apuntarse
a que un actor internacional de mucho
más peso como Naciones Unidas tendría
que darle fin a ese conflicto para
evitar a toda Costa un arma nuclear un
papel que ha jugado Turquía por ejemplo
que han estado a estas mesas de diálogo
Silvia terminó con ustedes este tema
para continuar con los otros temas que
tenemos en la agenda para el cierre su
conclusión perspectiva de lo que puede
pasar en los próximos días con Ucrania
al revés de la colega no no creo tanto
en esas soluciones diplomáticas
internacionales y uno toma como ejemplo
conflictos o momentos difíciles pero los
cuales algunos países están pasando y
hace un tiempo no uno puede tomar la
situación en Venezuela en que tantas
tanto se habló de una solución
diplomática de una presión diplomática
hace de una intervención y y nada de eso
funcionó la intervención obviamente no
pasó por suerte pero la idea de una de
una de más diplomacia de una diplomacia
más agresiva no funcionó De nada Y
tenemos ahí un dictador Nicolás Maduro
mucho más fuerte que antes obvio que
Venezuela no tiene armas nucleares y es
un conflicto mucho más pequeño pero eso
dudo un poco de la capacidad de la
comunidad internacional de de
actuar hasta hasta cierto punto y yo
creo que con los que dice que se agotó
el tema diplomático es porque él sigue
queriendo lo que él quería antes que era
más armas no para para que él pueda él
mismo y su ejército
avanzar de hecho sobre Rusia no sé es
una mirada muy particular de mi parte sí
Bueno pues también hubo anuncios
importantes en nuestra región en América
Latina dejamos de lado el tema de
Ucrania tema destacado de esta semana
tal vez el tema más importante en el
mundo entero durante estos cinco días
pero hubo anuncios muy importantes en
Colombia el gobierno de ese país que es
liderado por Gustavo Petro y la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional e Ln anunciaron la reanudación
de diálogos de paz después de cuatro
años de suspensión las partes acordaron
volver a establecer una mesa de diálogo
a partir de la primera semana del mes de
noviembre las conversaciones van a tener
sedes rotativas la primera está todavía
por definirse y van a contar con Cuba
Venezuela y Noruega como países garantes
también otros países como el reino de
España y chile también se mostraron
abiertos a como países sedes o como
países garantes para fomentar este
diálogo entre el gobierno colombiano y
esta guerrilla pues comienzo entonces
aquí en el en el estudio de France 24
con Camila preguntándole
esto es un respiro no un poco de
Esperanza para los colombianos ver otra
vez reactivada una mesa de diálogo o una
posibilidad de ver una paz certera
concreta con este grupo guerrillero
claro es una de más de las banderas del
presidente Gustavo Petro y es esa Paz
total y conseguir esa Paz total
esto sin duda Va a ser un hito histórico
porque es la primera vez que una
guerrilla de izquierda se sienta con un
gobierno de izquierda Entonces estamos
hablando de que se van a sentar dos muy
similares a hablar de algo que realmente
se ha buscado durante muchos muchos años
y es esa Paz total ahora estos diálogos
van a continuar con lo que venía
desarrollando Juan Manuel Santos y ellos
ya dijeron que van a continuar las
negociaciones y van a seguir en esa
misma línea lo cual es muy importante
pero también debemos tener en cuenta que
el Ln no es la misma guerrilla de Hace
seis años entonces es una guerrilla
muchísimo más fuerte con muchísimos más
actores líderes y esto puede a su vez
de tener un poco ese proceso hacia la
paz total y crear un poco de discusión
en cuanto a cuáles van a ser los
acuerdos y quiénes se van a ver
afectados con esos acuerdos porque entre
dos partes Pues siempre van a haber unos
que van a ganar más y otros que van a
ganar menos claro
sí es curioso porque en su momento
cuando estaba en el poder el presidente
Juan Manuel Santos él impulsó una mesa
de negociaciones con las con el Ln y Y
decía eso no que si no hacemos con todos
o todos juntos por otros grupos se va a
empeorar la situación bueno Iván Duque
levantó esta esta suspendió esta mesa y
ahora lo que tenemos es lo que decía la
colega un Ln mucho más fuerte y que no
necesariamente necesita la paz eso es
una una una una
un elemento que diferencia de hoy de las
partes del 2016 no el lln No
necesariamente necesita la paz no es
casi como Bueno podemos hacerlo por una
mejor Colombia podemos hacerlo porque
nos están pidiendo pero de parte de
ellos no no tienen interés por ejemplo
en
esos procesos de reintegración de la
sociedad o incluso cuestionó mucho la
la idea de un tribunal especial de paz o
sea para ellos el acuerdo de paz No no
va a ser como unos dicen en Colombia un
otro Sí simplemente aplicar el acuerdo
de las FARC con lln porque lln es una es
una guerrilla con muchas
particularidades
muchos otros modo de acción no no quiere
participar en el congreso como querían
las partes o sea es un acuerdo desde
cero Aunque hayan empezado uno y que fue
suspendido aún así muchas cosas son muy
distintas de las partes no es solo
firmar de nuevo un acuerdo con ellos no
Camila usted es ciudadana colombiana
conoce bien el tema está en la ciudad de
Bogotá permanentemente Pues viendo la
realidad del país obviamente viven en
Colombia usted como ciudadana lo ve con
esperanza Esto sí va a llegar a un buen
Puerto hay garantías para una mesa de
diálogo
que lleve a una conclusión
y termine con el conflicto Sí pues
realmente yo yo siempre he pensado en
esa frase de Y por qué no perseguir la
paz a lo que de Costa porque realmente
la paz creo que es algo que viene
necesitando toda Colombia y en sí toda
la región todo toda América Latina y
creo que estos diálogos si van a ser
fructíferos y van a poder ver
una luz porque es un gobierno que se
presta para eso es un gobierno que
realmente desde que se subió hace dos
meses ya dos meses después tiene una
fecha para implementar y empezar a
hablar otra vez de acuerdos Entonces se
está viendo que si hay una hay unas
ganas de caminar hacia allá y veo que sí
se puede lograr
ahora lo que decíamos eso Esto es algo
que va a tener fieles Y detractores
entonces también hay que mirar un poco
esos detractores y ver un poco esas esos
argumentos que también son válidos y es
la orden de captura de los talleres de
lln que es algo que también Pues digamos
pone a jugar algún papel muy alto y eso
son las regiones porque al final Bogotá
no vive la guerra la guerra está en el
catatumbo el norte de Santander la
guerra está en otro lado entonces abrir
un poco otra vez esa puerta a dejar
libre el Ln pues es problemático claro
para ir cerrando este tema Silvia ahí
también muchas discrepancias en torno a
los países garantes Cuba y Venezuela
Venezuela otra vez protagonista de temas
importantes para Colombia que podemos
decir sobre este tema Sí la verdad es
que poner a esos dos países como países
garantes una una un cuchillo de doble
filo no por un lado ellos estén tienen
un historial de haber participado de
manera exitosa en en el acuerdo de las
FARC no las negociaciones se dieron en
Cuba Venezuela y su inteligencia Y
juntos las guerrillas ayudó mucho y
no pasaría ahora no principalmente en el
tema de lln que tiene una relación un
vínculo más más fuerte con el sadismo y
mucha muchos de los miembros del ADN hoy
día están en el territorio venezolano
sería impensable hacer la paz sin la
presencia de Venezuela pero a la vez
tener a Nicolás Maduro tener el régimen
chavista como garante es un poco
deslegitimar el proceso una vez que es
una se trata de una dictadura no y el
mismo maduro tiene un doble discurso
sobre eso no porque preguntado en otras
en otros foros maduro negra incluso que
tenga nada que ver con el Ln o que el Ln
esté en su territorio y ahora de repente
no solo admite que sí está como también
va a ayudar a hablar con ellos o sea yo
creo que desde eslitimiza un poco el
proceso tener a dos dictaduras como
garantes no dos dos países que incumplen
derechos humanos de manera universal y
son y son
con frecuencia denunciados por eso por
otro lado de otra manera no O sea lo más
pragmático posible poner a maduro ahí ya
vamos a ver entonces a partir de la
primera semana de noviembre como empieza
Cómo se instala esta mesa de diálogo y a
ver qué conclusiones saca Mientras tanto
hablamos de la Cumbre de la Organización
de Estados Americanos oea que comenzó
también esta semana en la Ciudad de Lima
en Perú allí pues hubo varios temas
sobre la mesa pero el lema de este año
es juntos contra la desigualdad y la
discriminación el encuentro también
ha debatido sobre otros temas
importantes que están sobre la mesa en
nuestra región de América Latina por
ejemplo democracia vulnerabilidad
economía migración que sigue siendo un
problema transversal para todas la
región por ejemplo desde Estados Unidos
hubo varios anuncios en torno a ayudas
para el tema migratorio para los países
que se están viendo afectados esto pues
claramente va en dirección a México en
los países Centroamericanos pero también
a Colombia de Panamá y también hubo buen
apoyo digamoslo así a ese plan de paz
Total que estamos mencionando que
Colombia fue presentó allí en esta
organización ante todos los países del
continente hubo rechazo no en bloques Ya
lo vamos a analizar de la invasión de
Rusia a Ucrania por primera vez la
región se manifestó de una forma un poco
más oficial y organizada sobre este
conflicto y también hubo varios
cuestionamientos sobre el reconocimiento
de Juan guaidó como presidente o
autoproclamado presidente de Venezuela
ya vamos a ver entonces esta figura de
la política Venezolana en que está en
este momento comienza entonces con
Silvia
preguntándole por por este tema de
desigualdad discriminación que son los
temas bandera de de esta Cumbre Pero qué
tanto peso tiene la oea y estas Cumbres
ese es un tema a debatirse también no
porque cualquier cosa que salga de la
oea va a ser un documento un relatorio y
los países que más están afectados por
por ese problemas quizás ni siquiera lo
mire no piensa un poco en mi país Brasil
donde la oea y cualquier organización
internacional es considerada por el
presidente como algo
parte de algún complot comunista como
alguna internacional de de de de países
rojos que quieren meterse en Brasil o
sea ese tipo de documento o de o de
institución de entidad no hace ni ruido
en sus oídos no entonces
Habría que ver cómo cómo hacer llegar
ese tipo de mensaje a donde
verdaderamente tiene que llegar por otro
lado creo que cuando la olla habla de
desigualdad en una Colombia de hoy en
Chile de hoy es otro otro tema porque
son países mucho más abiertos a la
participación a escuchar este tipo de de
balance no con la relación de otros
temas Me parece que lo de guaidó Fue
bastante decisivo No a algunos países ya
quisieron salir del apoyo que le dieron
hace unos años no Argentina fue uno de
ellos no y me parece que eso muestra un
poco
bastante como guaidó viene viene
desgastándose como líder opositor en
Venezuela a pocos meses de que tengamos
primarias para las elecciones del año
del año siguiente en Venezuela no
entonces creo que es una movida
importante que haga acompañar Y qué pasa
con el apoyo internacional a guaidó Sí
ese tal vez uno de los de los debates
que deja hasta esta cumbre de la oea
Camila pero también uno se pregunta si
estas Cumbres y estas organizaciones
continentales y están teniendo peso en
sus decisiones Porque además no ve uno
un desfile de presidentes como vimos en
la Cumbre de las Américas vemos
cancilleres vicepresidentes funcionarios
nadie quería ir va a tomarse la foto con
Pedro Castillo sí Ese es un poco del
análisis y también es un poco ver que la
vea Pues igual está presidida por
Estados Unidos eso algo bien importante
en esta coyuntura de la guerra con Rusia
y Ucrania porque occidente levanta la
cabeza a la manera en que occidente
levanta la cabeza y es mediante mediante
estas organizaciones Que reúnen a toda
la región Entonces es un poco que
comparto lo que decía la colega es un
poco el papel que va a salir de una
reunión más en la que estuvieron muchos
líderes que poco pueden hacer porque a
la final lo que quiere y lo que se
muestra es que occidente está presente
pero está presente y no va a estar a la
final o no tiene un hecho concreto sobre
lo que puede hacer entonces se sientan
los líderes a hablar y abanderarse un
poco de todo lo que han logrado y todo
lo que han hecho y es difícil corroborar
esa información es difícil saber si
realmente de la Cumbre hasta este punto
se ha logrado algo de lo que han dicho
Entonces si es un poco más una bandera
para decir aquí estamos somos occidente
somos Unidos pero realmente Hasta qué
punto y hay temas además al interior de
la región que están mucho más
preocupantes como por ejemplo el tema
migratorio que es de Gran preocupación y
la situación de Cuba de Nicaragua y de
Venezuela ahí sí posiciones divididas
nadie se quiere mojar nadie quiere tomar
partida o iniciativa para para algo y y
el tema de los migrantes pues recaen
unos países muy puntuales pero es una
gran problemática sí es una gran
problemática y es algo a lo que Estados
Unidos también le da apuntado muchísimo
y esas a solucionar ese tema de la
migración ahora lo que sucede en Cuba lo
que sucede en Nicaragua y lo que sucede
en Venezuela Pues es que son gobiernos
dictatoriales que realmente están
generando una presión sin precedentes en
sus en sus tierras en sus pueblos y
invitado a que sean condenados por
muchos pero pero a la hora de tomar
cartas en el asunto Pues así como se
dice Mejor no porque como decía o como
dijo Gustavo Petro nuestro presidente
acá en Colombia también se violan los
Derechos Humanos entonces quién soy yo
para ir a decirle a los otros que deben
hacer y es un poco algo problemático
porque al final son gobiernos estos
estos se supone que es un gobierno
democrático frente a un gobierno que es
autocrático entonces pues realmente la
realidad es No son no son las mismas
aunque se quieran exactamente Silvia su
opinión
no veo un futuro inmediato en que la
migración se deje de producir en
nuestros países porque la situación
económica solo la veo más grave o por lo
menos mejorado un poquito y para pocos
en la región
crisis que son que son graves y vienen
intensas hace unos meses o años siguen
intensos como la edad de Haití que ha
provocado migraciones no solo
directamente desde Haití pero de
haitianos que salen de Brasil de chile y
que cruzan el el tapón de Darién
hay migrantes de de otros países de Perú
de Venezuela que tampoco han bajado y
vamos a tener un año de reajustes de
nuevos gobiernos tomando medidas
impopulares
tenemos tasas de desempleo y de
informalidad muy altos no no están dadas
las condiciones para que esas
migraciones disminuyen no no y el caso
de Cuba ahora tenemos un factor extra el
huracán las dificultades que se están
pasando en la isla de hecho tuvimos un
récord en los últimos meses de cubanos
saliendo de Cuba como ciudad todavía
hubiera espacio para eso pero sí siguen
saliendo cubanos de Cuba O sea que yo
creo que para el tema de la de la
migración no veo un escenario favorable
en los próximos meses mientras lo
mejoren las economías locales no y lo
mismo vale para Centroamérica y la
violencia Centroamérica claro no y los
esfuerzos parece que no son suficientes
porque es que no es solamente la
dificultad económica la seguridad son
las garantías son múltiples los factores
que llevan a las personas a tener que
abandonar sus sus países de origen y la
situación en general no es que esté muy
bien en los otros países en donde hay
tal vez menos dificultades económicas
Pues hay inseguridad en donde hay
inseguridad Entonces no hay opciones de
trabajo entonces
no es tan fácil para la gente
simplemente tomar su mochila y irse y
Buscar un nuevo futuro y sobre todo en
Estados Unidos tampoco las cosas están
tan tan fantásticamente vistas en
términos económicos Bueno vamos llegando
al bloque final de el programa ya hasta
el tiempo se nos va pasando volando lo
mencionábamos hace algunos minutos esta
fue semana de entrega de premios Nobel
esta semana conocimos entonces a los
ganadores de las categorías de
fisiología o medicina física química
literatura y Paz Como cada año está
entrega de premios que son suecos y
noruegos
generan controversia hay muchos
señalamientos sobre la lo que se ha
politizado la entrega de estos premios y
se critica también que se han visto
amañados en cuanto a las nominaciones a
la selección que hace la Real Academia
sueca de ciencias o al instituto
carolinska o la academia sueca también
el comité noruego de El Nobel que es el
que entrega el premio Nobel de paz
tendríamos pendiente todavía el premio
de económicas comienzo con Silvia
entonces Silvia siente usted aquí está
este sentimiento de politización en
estos premios en estas críticas y le
dejo de una vez sobre la mesa para
responder más adelante esa controversia
que hubo entre el presidente de México
Andrés Manuel López Obrador porque
criticó que hubieran nominado al
presidente zelensky al Premio Nobel de
paz
Sí eso La verdad no no veo un problema
en que en que por lo menos el premio
Nobel de paz sea politizado porque ya
hay antecedentes de que el premio Nobel
incluso ya ayudó a resolver conflictos
no el caso mismo de Colombia es uno de
esos no justo después que él no venció
el plebiscito de la paz en el 2016 fue
la entrega del premio Nobel de la Juan
Manuel Santos lo que llevó yo yo no
nuevo aliento y y a sus dos de alguna
manera fue un elemento que ayudó a al
final el acuerdo pasar en el congreso no
sé si la colega colombiana va a estar de
acuerdo pero para mí fue una un elemento
positivo así que yo no veo que sea
negativo que el Nobel de paz sea
politizado cómo pasó en este año ahora
en que el premio fue entrega un
activista de ver la luz y y a ongs de
Derechos Humanos en Rusia y Ucrania que
están sufriendo un montón para ayudar a
la gente que está sufriendo exactamente
en este mismo momento no Ya sí me parece
un poco un poco distinto cuando se trata
de literatura porque la literatura es
algo un poco más distinto y despegado de
la de la realidad inmediata y creo que
así debe ser con el arte no Entonces
cuando se premiaba un escritor solo por
ser de un país de minorías olvidado
preso político a ella no sé Ahí sí yo
creo que lo que tiene que valer más es
la localidad de su literatura por este
lado Camila Bueno yo veo de hecho
positivo que el Nobel algo político
porque es es un premio que tiene mucha
visibilidad mucha visibilidad entonces
realmente sí creo que se puede mandar un
mensaje a través de quienes ganan el
premio Nobel en el caso en este caso el
premio Nobel de paz que lo dan hoy el
día que Vladimir putenco cumple 70 años
pues es realmente algo que mandó un
mensaje y lo dan a un activista
bielorruso que está preso lo dan a una
organización de derechos humanos de
Ucrania y una de Rusia y muestra un poco
que en un contexto todo si pueden vivir
juntos O sea que Hay ciertos líderes que
hacen la vida difícil pero que en un
contexto en el de la sociedad civil se
puede vivir pueden vivir todos juntos
entonces manda claramente un mensaje muy
contundente y me parece que es algo
positivo porque en realidad todo el
mundo se entera de este tipo de premios
todo el mundo está muy al tanto que es
lo que pasa con este tipo de tipo de
premios y
pequeñas organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos digamos está de momento en que
fue la que ganó en Rusia en Rusia en
Rusia tampoco funciona ya en Rusia
Entonces es un poco visibilizar esos
esfuerzos que ellos han hecho poco a
poco y esos esfuerzos que de pronto no
vemos Nosotros por estar solamente
mirando una guerra de un lado y una
guerra del otro Entonces sí es muy
importante que es tal vez lo que nos
pasa con el tema de celensky Tal vez de
ahí viene la indignación del presidente
mexicano estaba completamente indignado
y lo dijo en su conferencia matutina que
no le parecía que fueran nominado el
presidente de Ucrania bolo de mercelesky
al Premio Nobel de paz y esto generó un
revuelo en redes sociales impresionante
por este lado opiniones Camila claro
tiene un discurso
y maneja una retórica muy fuerte pero en
un punto
dar un premio a Pues a un presidente
También toma un color muy muy definido
se les quita también tiene tropas en el
terreno peleando y también ha causado
muertes entonces un poco verlo por ese
lado es es un poco sí salirse de eso y
más bien premiar a la sociedad civil que
es la que está luchando y que es la que
tiene la batalla por la mano ahora por
otro lado se le reconoce hacen lo que ha
hecho claramente y podría también ganar
el premio claramente porque lo ha
llevado lo ha llevado muy bien y ha
logrado sacar esta guerra Ha logrado que
el mundo entero pues por lo menos sienta
un poco empatía por Ucrania que es un
país invadido Silvia rápidamente su
opinión sobre este tema de amlo y
selensky Estoy totalmente de acuerdo con
con la colega y es curioso que se le
tuiteó creo que fue hasta mañana o
anoche una un mensaje diciendo sobre los
líderes latinoamericanos los procesos
latinoamericanos En qué lado estarían en
este momento con relación a la guerra
Ucrania de Rusia contra Ucrania no y
nombra a Miguel Hidalgo
un prócer de la independencia mexicana
de qué lado estaría él se estaría de mi
lado estaría al lado del opresor no un
poco me pareció como una provocación de
vuelta a López Obrador Claro claro
totalmente provocando al presidente
mexicano para el cierre rápidamente Qué
temas van a tener ustedes bajo la lupa
la próxima semana en sus redacciones en
sus artículos en sus investigaciones en
lo que estén trabajando Camila A qué le
va a poner la lupa esta semana pues la
lupa esta semana está sin duda en las
relaciones con Venezuela en la apertura
de las fronteras en lo que va a suceder
y cómo va a ser también ese un poco ese
tráfico y cómo va a resurgir un poco esa
relación con maduro es muy importante
para para Colombia el tema de la paz
total Y seguramente los delegados de la
paz estarán muy atentos también de
Silvia rápidamente muy puntual por favor
porque se me acaba el tiempo por favor
claro bueno en primer lugar para
facilitar también estoy con el tema Paz
total intentando explicar mejor al
lector brasilero que es el Ln Y por qué
ese acuerdo es tan distinto Y cuánto va
a tomar y después todo el tiempo que hay
en Brasil hoy día está lleno está está
tomado por la agenda brasilera en esas
elecciones que tenemos Pues a Silvia
Camila les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Pedro Ruiz y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera gracias por su sintonía sigan
con Franz 24
[Música]